gentlemen welcome to the forge in front
of your anvils you guys have a sealed
mission brief go ahead and open those up
for me
we are calling this Mission zero
it's a brute to forge challenge in round
one of the competition I want you guys
to build me knives made out of this
scrap metal here
no cutting tools no Grinders no hot
cutting your blade needs to be between
12 and 14 inches and have a full tank
your time starts now
my name is Josh Wentz 31 years old I
like to consider myself a full-time dad
part-time knife maker there's a lot more
time with my son than there is in my
shop I'm definitely not complaining he's
a ball of joy and I'm happy every day
that I need to be with him it looks like
Josh is not cutting anything off that
round stock I weld my stick to my steel
and then muscle memory kicks in I throw
it right into the forge he's probably
got almost two pounds of metal there
McDonald's on me that I forgot to cut
any excess Material off normally I would
step over the grinder start getting that
edge thickness down to where I want it
but instead I'm sitting here planishing
my steel I'm showing you all the rough
Hammer marks out of it right now
I'm ready to finally quench this knife
Josh is quenched it's nice and hard it's
straight it's still heavy but I couldn't
have asked for anything more my name is
menel m-e-n-n-n-n-o not like to fish I
sit on the phone the whole day saying
thank you for calling you know what this
is meno local food no face don't talk
man
when I saw the show for the first time I
didn't know nothing about knife making
so I made a forge I made a little sword
out of a nail cut myself with it and I
was intrigued as I'm looking at the
table I can see a piece of Steel and I
think it's W4 and that is great metal
right now I'm going from Big Blue to the
press back to measuring big blue press
I'm super happy with my blade um it's
the right size it's the right width it's
the right weight I think they're gonna
love it and it will cut now that I'm
getting ready for the quench I make sure
that my temperatures are good
that was harsh I'm so happy I will be
surprised if I don't go through the next
round because it's a beautiful blade
my name is Brad Diddy I'm 23 years old
growing up I always wanted to have a
forge but my dad would look at me and go
I don't trust you with it to be a forge
and fire Champion would make everyone at
home proud and that would just put a
huge smile on my face
so I'm staring at the table and I'm
feeling a little bit of angst in my gut
which one is going to be the best steel
for me to use and immediately I'm
thinking it's the leaf spring I'm doing
my very best to create a perfect and
symmetrical Edge down the center and
also keep the spine nice and thick it
looks pretty darn good
now that my blade fits the parameters
and has a nice shape to it I'm getting
ready to quench
and it's not hard
at this moment I am really kind of let
down but it's not time to give up
Brad's back in the Forge after he
quenched re-quenching might affect my
blade in the testing but it's up to God
not me
I run the file across it and it skates
thank you Jesus
five four three two one put down your
tools this round is over congratulations
you guys are moving into round two in
front of you've got ammo cans you'll
also see a bunch of spent ammo casings I
want you guys to integrate those into
the construction of your Handles in some
way shape or form your time starts now
I've got to adjust my handle so the
judges feel more secure holding that
knife in their hands I'm not worried
about my handle material being perfect I
just need to get the holes in there so
the holes I'm just going to use five
five six rounds as a pin stock they're
long enough to fit through my handle and
I know they're long enough to grab onto
the handle material I'm feeling pretty
good I'm doing my rough shaping of my
handle material
okay I've watched this competition
enough times to see people go home for
uncomfortable handles it's something
that you need to be thinking about all
right I wanted to make the nicest
handles out of the pantry not with these
things I immediately see the 22 shelves
and I hope that's going to be the same
size as my holes
perfect
the bullet shells that I'm using do
three pin stocks in it with glue so that
is then the pin stock it's more like a
Corby Bowl then I can go immediately to
the grinder it's all fitted it could not
have been better
I'm done with the handle and try to make
it as sharp as possible
I have to include a bullet round casing
into my handle as I'm staring at my
table I notice that there is a short 22
shell and a long one if these can go
together maybe I can pinch the one in I
can turn this into a tube instead of a
shell and use it as a pin
yes and they fit perfectly I couldn't
ask for anything better all right
try this one I'm looking I see acrylic
which I've used but however I know is
very brittle so you got to be very
careful with it the super glue won't
open oh the Top's coming off that's not
good
oh way too much way too much and deep
everywhere it's on my hands it's on the
painters tape ah my pieces are glued
together I am extremely nervous what if
I can't get these apart
it's acrylic so I have to be very very
careful
thank God it pops apart try that one
more time hippie now that my handle's
all clamped up I figure it's good enough
time for me to go over to the grinder
my Edge is just about to the point where
I want it to be I start shaping my
handle
if I were to win a ten thousand dollars
I give two thousand to the church right
away but the other five thousand or
eight whatever the whatever how it goes
shakes out in the end I probably just
put in the bank I'm really not good at
math I told you that five four three two
one place your weapons down turn off
your machines this round is over all
right gentlemen I think you know what
time it is it's time for the strength
test
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades I will be
swinging into these ammo cans Josh
you're up first you ready let's do it
[Music]
oh
all right Josh when I grab your handle
right off it's comfortable your use of
the shells for the pulse is great it
would have been nice to file the insides
of them off the weight of your knife
it's good it feels pretty right on your
Edge you've got a couple spots up the
tip that are more chips than rolls and
then down here you've got rolls but good
job thank you all right minnow you're up
you ready cut it in half
[Music]
all right
all right so minnow I'm not a huge fan
of finger grooves but this is sized
beautifully for my hand as far as the
blade goes we have chips here as opposed
to a roll where it's too soft this is
It's just brittle it leaves some
question about the heat treat you can
see the grains are really big I mean it
looks like more of a sand than that
velvet you want to see but all in all
good job thank you
all right Brad you're up you ready I'm
glad I wore my brown pants
[Laughter]
foreign
first off as far as your handle goes
pretty much right where I want it having
that Palm swell there it sits in it fits
my hand really nicely on the blade
you've got primarily rolls here there's
a couple of chips but uh good feel well
done good done thank you very much I
appreciate it this is the sharpest test
the military bed slice
to find out how sharp your edges are I
will take your knife and do some slices
on this canvas military bed Joshua first
you ready for this let's do it
[Music]
all right Josh let's talk about your
blade here first up when I grab onto
your handle there are no sharp edges at
all it's comfortable in my hand your
Edge you have a really rolled spot over
here that took some material with it but
the rest of the blade is very sharp it
will cut thank you Mano your turns are
you ready yeah
[Music]
oh
right then let's talk about your blade
here first up it's a forward heavy blade
but the construction that you have for
the handle actually locks it in so I
have a very good grip on this now let's
talk about your Edge the areas where
these chips actually hit the canvas it
ripped rather than cut but the edges
that did make contact that are sharp cut
easily overall sir it'll cut thank you
all right Brad your turn are you ready
sir not as ready as you let's do this
foreign
Brad let's talk about your blade here
first up it's light but it's strong and
it's easy to wield your edge here had
some rolling earlier in the strength
test but the movement of this blade
allows me to move it to where I can get
the cuts in overall sir
it'll cut thank you
gentlemen we give you a very hard task
in Mission zero but you all proved your
worth in the Forge unfortunately one of
you will not be going forward into round
three the competition and that blade
Smith is
Meadow
Ben Abbott will tell you why
well your blade took significant
chipping in the strength test exposing
large brittle grains those big chips
also affected its ability in The Cutting
test and it's for those reasons that
we're letting you go okay fair better I
want to say thank you for all your hard
work but at this time I'm gonna have to
ask you to leave the fourth floor thank
you so much
I did not expect that my blade would
crack or or that it was that brittle I'm
gonna go home I'm gonna go sit in the
bathtub with a knife kiss the puppies
hug the wife I'll keep a forging it's
that's not the end of the world I loved
doing this
foreign